look at them fluffy tough loving the
Dove and having a full of the duck
love the Dove sounds dirty I'm loving
the dub no isn't that that sounds like
it if you like to make a mistake you
like oh man
love the dub or Pablo I think you just
it means like can you just don't work
you're not he's just loving it done no
it's going off
I think it's jerking on field to avoid
ones work or duties okay so you're not
follow things okay
are you gonna get down to your working
yarnís kids fun the job all day foofaraw
Hoover ah you are looking to Ferrar
tonight that's like a rager he went over
to David's it was a point of foofaraw
allowed disturbance what are these kids
do not vote for us but kinda like a
bruja yeah like a ruckus fun struggle
this sounds like a hair problem that was
one like you would go to a restaurant
and you wouldn't get enough buns free
meal I'm out of dread and you're like oh
lunch drive behind on in that bunch of
other life a full multi a formal tea so
the opposite of the struggle look at me
yeah no struggle but in ski in ski
that's like the guy you hate on your
football team yeah like he's always in
trouble yeah always
I bet but in ski something cool okay a
person who rudely intrudes himself
always you my beloved I am gonna go back
and use all these words that flame today
is way shorter we get like piss if we
have to type lol that's three letters
years from now when we're dead they'll
be like why the hell did you say
awesomesauce
you say rat a lot that's rad oh really
yeah what did Netflix and chill means
who creates all these words and that
makes them popular well
in the dove I mean that's what we know
what that means we could bring that back